good morning believe nation today's
message is dream big over to you Novak
Djokovic Belgrade as many cities around
Serbia has suffered a lot because of war
many people have had the doubts of
Ottoman rings they were not certain they
are able to support their children and
in this particular situation were my
parents to knowing what we have been
through actually strengthened my my
character is to run around outside of
our restaurant and very nearby something
was going on some kind of construction
ask the workers and then they told me
that they're building tennis courts I
never heard the word tennis I knew
football and some other sports but
tennis was absolutely new to me into my
family fell in love instantly with the
sport I used to play for hours against
the wall
on the television I watched Pete Sampras
play for his first Wimbledon title
that's when I decided to dream big and
dream about being one day and the center
court of Wimbledon holding the trophy so
I really love this short clip for three
main reasons the first is here's this
guy coming from this country that he's
had a lot of things against him right he
had a lot of bad luck you had a lot of
you know just from his circumstances a
lot of people there would give up a lot
of people say well you know I can't do
anything look at where I'm coming from I
don't live in America I don't have these
huge opportunities and he saw that he
saw this struggle that he went through
as making him stronger he started as a
positive that helped make him stronger
to go out and accomplish something more
where a lot of people see it as a
weakness
he saw it as a benefit and something to
made him stronger and I love it
the second thing that I loved was that
he explored until he found something
that he loved knowing this is a really
young age but where other kids were
playing soccer and playing other sports
he heard of they built these random
tennis courts in his hometown and he
picked it up and he went and tried
something new and he fell in love with
it right if you don't know what you want
to do or if you don't love the work that
you're doing you need to explore things
until you find the thing that you love
he picked up the tennis racket and he
just couldn't put it down he was playing
for hours and hours and hours just
hitting the ball against the wall cos he
loved it he fell in love with it he
didn't have to convince himself that he
loved it he actually loved it and so you
need to do the same thing where other
people might be playing soccer whatever
the equivalent is right the the easy
safe things where other people are doing
this this and that and then this weird
thing comes up that nobody knows about
give it a shot see what happens the
worst thing is you try it once and you
hate it but you might try and want to
unloved it and you could be Novak
Djokovic level at that or if you didn't
try it you wouldn't know so explore
things until you find a thing that makes
you come alive and then the third thing
is model success like he sees Pete
Sampras on TV and that allows him to
have a bigger dream for himself where
his environment might be might be
smaller you know nobody that he knows
have had that kind of success maybe
people he knows hasn't broken free of
the country or have gone on to do big
things
model success he turns on the TV he sees
Pete Sampras killing it he's like I want
to go do that so having people that you
can model look up to like
you know I have people here behind me on
the wall they're there for reason I
modeled the success they helped me be
the best version of me and so those
three things is what I took from the
super short video I'm really excited
about making his top 10 rule so I think
we have to make sure that comes up
pretty quickly so the question date
today is are you dreaming big enough for
your business for your life leave it in
the comments below and I will join in
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Erik Sanchez Erik thank you
so much for buying my book it means a
lot to me but those are you watching if
you want your chance at a shadow in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and email us your receipts
and we'll let you into the draw thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso